and here to tell us a little more about
the battle against space junk is an
expert from the German Aerospace Center
man with Mets know is that really true
do we need garbage removal in space how
high is the risk that a satellite could
get hit by a piece of space debris well
there's actually a risk there a lot of
objects in orbit we know there are about
twenty two thousand objects larger than
10 centimeter in orbit they're about
750,000 objects larger than 1 centimeter
and about 150 million objects larger
than 1 millimeter in orbit and credible
where do all these objects come from oh
these objects come from from all the
space activities from the past
satellites have been launched into orbit
and they have to be left there after the
mission and sometimes you have
explosions in orbits especially of upper
stages of rockets and the those events
produce all these this space debris and
and with every coalition I suppose you
the problem gets even bigger right
absolutely if it seems that we are
currently in there at the rim of a
process where debris collides with each
other and produces more and more debris
even if we would not launch any any more
satellites into orbit mm-hmm and is
there a chance to actually protect the
satellites from a coalition well you can
only protect satellites from collisions
with small pieces of debris I've by
installing shield exactly been stalling
some kind of shield this is an example
here is an aluminum plate which was hit
by an object which is of a millimeter
size with the speed of 250 thousand
kilometers per hour and you can see that
there's a large hole in this is PC is
that is that from space now no this was
from an experiment here on earth uh-huh
and which orbit in space is actually the
most messy one well the most messy one
is at altitudes of about 18 800
kilometers 800 to 1,000 kilometers so
that's where all the weather satellites
are and the spy satellites for example
exactly Earth observation satellites for
example the ether satellite and we sort
this orbital region now the German
Aerospace Center is also planning to
capture discarded satellites what's your
how is your system working well there's
a satellite mission planned which is
called deals the German orbital
servicing mission and this is a
satellite equipped with a robotic arm to
capture a satellite in orbit maybe we
could take it the pictures you brought
us and you could describe what's
actually happening with the satellite
you capture so the green one is now
satellite which we also brought into
orbit which is to be captured you can
see on the right hand side the servicer
with the robotic arm is capturing the
satellite the tumbling satellite and
what does that work this is by a robotic
arm with kind of gripper 22 from the
attached to satellite and now you can
see this is the final phase of the
mission we're both satellites from the
attached together our deorbited into
Earth's atmosphere but that actually
means that with every discarded
satellite you capture you lose the deal
system that's pretty expensive is that
would be absolutely correct so deal
system has a second objective which is
we want to show that it's that we are
able to survey satellites in orbit to
perform maintenance operations refueling
for example thanks up for the talk
Margaret soon